Android 5.0 Lollipop, or API 21,
added new ways to better choreograph
moving between activities.
Firstly, a new API let's you to run
a transition when you launch or
leave an activity.
This allows you to customize how
individual views in the screen,
enter or exit.
We call these content transitions.
Secondly, it added the ability to
create a shared element transition.
This is where an element,
which is present on two screens,
transitions smoothly between them.
The result is visual continuity for
shared elements across
the two activities.
Before we dive deeper into
these powerful new APIs,
let's take a second to talk a little
bit about backwards compatibility.
So far in the course,
almost everything we've covered
has been achievable on all
relevant versions of Android.
Especially with the help of Android
support libraries like AppCompat.
As we've seen in this lesson,
the Android animation APIs have become
more powerful with each release.
This means that some of the more
advanced effects might be impossible or
unfeasible to achieve on older devices.
A generally good approach for
implementing animations,
is to use the newest APIs but to then
degrade gracefully on all the devices,
swapping in simple animations for
the more complex ones.
Remember, that devices are constantly
being refreshed and upgraded.
So while working on the newest API's
might have a lower uptake at first,
the return on investment will only grow.
Okay, let's take a closer look at
the new activity transitions in 5.0.